Hello Freak bitches.
I find,
you know,
like I said,
vandelay probably one of my all time favorite guys to watch because you see it
was pure chaos,
but I find that people like yourself oftentimes make really good analysts
because like you were a guy who is like looking at fighting,
whether it's mma,
stand up on the ground,
whatever it was,
you're looking at it at this very analytical level.
It's for me it's like asking questions.
That's one of my boxing coaches.
Kenny welding used to say that when I thought Aaron the second time he watched
the fight after the fact and he was like,
was like,
so what do you think?
And he goes,
good.
It has a lot of questions.
Is like,
what do you mean?
He has a lot of questions.
He's like,
every time you do something you're asking them a question and then I'm sorry,
every time he does something,
he's asking you a question and you're answering him with like,
I'm going to do this and what are you going to do about what I'm doing?
And he's just asking me why are you doing that?
Why are you doing that?
So he's like,
he's saying he's asking all the questions,
but he has no answers.
So he's asking me questions.
I'm giving him matches and um,
I think that's Kinda how I watched fight.
So how I fought,
I would try to do something and see what you're doing because of that.
You kind of play with that and feel it.
And,
and that's how I watch other people fly to watch.
When I watch guys fight,
I'm like,
what is he doing?
Why is he doing that?
Is he trying to set something up?
Is this guy going to react?
How is that guy going to react to that?
What's he going to do about him?
What's he going to do about his strengths?
He knows he's coming in with these strengths.
So how is he going to try and take those things away?
Well,
he just going to try to impose his own strengths.
I,
for me,
that's what fighting is.
It's be making yourself as comfortable as you can be at all times while making
the other guy as uncomfortable as he can be.
For me,
that's what I,
I tried to look at and I tried to see if guys play like that,
how the,
how are they going to play that game?
Yeah.
That completely makes sense that you had that kind of style with that approach.
You know,
I just always admired the way you would set things up.
You always had a real technical style,
which I mean,
like I said,
I admire chaos to admire those Melvin manhoef dudes too.
You know,
I admire vandelay like maybe more than anybody just because it was so wild to
watch.
But um,
I find,
I find that for analysis like Dominick Cruz is another guy I think knocks it out
of park because he's so,
so smart and his assessment of risk and reward and putting yourself in a
position where your opponent doesn't exactly know what you're going to do,
but you know how he's gonna react because you're,
you have this awkward style that you've seen other people react to for a long
time.
But for them it's like this new thing.
They're standing in front of this guy who's switching stances and bouncing and
moving up and down and back and forth,
and you're not exactly sure what the fuck he's doing,
but he knows what you're going to do because he's so used to doing it to regular
people,
like everybody who stands like you,
like certain guys that you have that like more Thai style and God there.
There's so much that they're giving a guy in that situation and when you got a
guy like dominick Cruz,
like he's not predictable at all.
He's like flipping stances and moving around and throwing punches from these
weird fucking angles where you would swear he's doing it wrong.
Right?
Yeah.
It's for me,
I always look at the way someone explained something to me is the easiest way to
explain it.
And Ben asked Grin.
Tyron said,
Ben Likes to cause scrambles,
right?
That's what dom does.
He's causing scrambles on the feet because he's.
He's not in the traditional position.
He's not in.
He's not coming at you like everybody else does.
So what he's doing is initiating and scrambled right away.
When you're.
When you get a guy on top of you like Rda and he's good at establishing
position,
if you can create a scramble,
then you have a better chance of getting out than if you,
than if you just try to use basic technique.
And Dominic is comfortable in those scrambles.
He,
he's been in them so many times.
When you react you have like three or four reactions.
But he has like 22.
Wow.
Damn.
You know,
he did a great breakdown.
A cure from the underground cure genesis.
Yeah.
He uh,
see if he could find that he put it up today.
He put up a,
a,
an article breaking down all the variables of dominick Cruz's footwork.
Really interesting stuff because you don't until you see it as a list,
like all the different things he does.
And kubrick did an awesome job of,
of just sort of a breaking down all the different things in his fights and it
just makes you realize like,
wow,
that guy's got a lot of options to like someone was,
I think it was Ludwig,
was saying that he doesn't think he has good technique.
And how can you say that though,
because he lands so many punches,
like how can you say it?
Like it might not look like everybody else's.
But goddamn,
it's working.
I mean,
it works.
It's crazy how effective it is.
See,
this is all this stuff that,
that Kirk wrote down,
all the different stuff that dominic does.
Pretty interesting,
right?
A neo footwork is what people are calling it,
So like a Tj dillashaw style.
He's got a very interesting style too.
And uh,
I uh,
I hit pads with Dwayne recently.
Dwayne showed me some stuff and one of the things he's doing is all he's
switched stances.
He's doing like these you're switching and throwing punches as you're switching.
He's got a lot of this switch stance stuff that he's rick really incorporating
into these combinations.
And you see it a lot from tj.
I mean Tj is as comfortable from a south paws.
He is from an Orthodox and he's doing a lot of these switch moves.
Like they're,
they're hitting pads with these and they're very confused,
you know.
So remember when I said I don't like that style,
that Geeky pseudo style because not because,
but dominic style,
that style I think is the style to beat that.
The reason I say that is because the way dominic is approaching it,
he's approaching it from a educated,
I would say,
more educated,
more studious place.
These guys are approaching it from trying to get you to buy the wolf ticket.
You know,
so they're.
They're giving you these weird looks because that's gonna make you get off
balance,
get.
I'd stand there for them.
Be The guy that's just a target.
But dom is giving you these looks from a fighting perspective.
He's always in position to fight those guys.
When you're.
When you're breakdancing,
sometimes you're not in position to react.
Dom is always imposition to react and that's why I think that style is the style
that beats the other style.
10 out of 10 times.
What's really interesting is I don't recall anybody before dominick Cruz doing
it like that.
A really don't it.
It's a lot of what.
I mean,
it's limited,
but Mohammed Ali did a lot of things like that with his boxing,
you know,
the rope and open his footwork that that's,
that's a part of it.
That's a part of what dom does.
Dom does it for MMA,
so he has to be aware of the kicks,
tie ups and clenches.
I mean,
how many times do you see guys press dom on the fence?
Almost never.
Never.
Very rarely.